- Even to this day,
we continue to follow the music.
We work with the most
famous drummers in the world
to make the sounds that they need,
so they can make music.
(cymbals tapping)
(drums beating)
My name's Paul Francis,
and I'm a cymbal maker
for the Avedis Zildjian company.
Cymbal making has remained the same
for almost 400 years.
Zildjian Cymbal goes back to 1623.
We're part of this
legacy of cymbal making,
and it's really, really exciting
that we're continuing this history.
(cymbals crashing)
We make well over 600 models
in different diameters,
and it's much like if you're a carpenter,
you don't have one tool, you
have a toolbox full of tools.
So, as a drummer, the cymbals
are part of your toolbox.
OK, you have a big cymbal like this,
it's called a ride cymbal,
so you keep time on it.
These are hi-hats, and
these are two cymbals
that come together.
Then you have crash cymbals,
and these all offer
different sound colors,
so the drummer can express
himself in a nonverbal way
within the context of the piece of music.
(drum cymbal music)
Cymbal making is a lot
like being a blacksmith
or a farrier.
There's a lot of steps that
go into making a cymbal
and, you know, it could
take a couple days.
(cymbal crashing)
We're gonna take that casting;
we're gonna throw it in an oven.
And we're gonna shape it;
we're gonna hammer it;
we're gonna shave it;
we're gonna lathe it;
goes down to a cymbal
test, so he plays it.
(cymbal crashes)
- Sound quality, cosmetic quality,
we look for it all.
(cymbal crashes)
- I've had the privilege to work with
a lot of great drummers.
Steve Gadd, Elvin Jones,
Zak Starkey, who was
actually Ringo Starr's son.
Zak plays in The Who and
a variety of other bands.
And Carter Beauford,
Carter Beauford plays for
the Dave Matthews Band.
The list goes on and on.
(dramatic cymbal crashing)
I've been here for 30 years.
It's really fantastic
that I'm actually part
of the world of music and music
that's going to be created
or has been created, and
it's my job right now
to make sure that my
knowledge gets passed on
to the next people that
are gonna continue it
for the next 400 years.
(various drum and cymbal music)